schon seit 1969 gibt es das internet
damals ins leben gerufen durch das
amerikanische verteidigungsministerium
und schon schnell vor allem als
kommunikationsmittel zwischen
forschungseinrichtungen benutzt 1989
wurde dann das world wide web
am cern in genf entwickelt das über
webseiten erstmals einfach dokumente mit
links darstellen konnte
seitdem haben und meilensteine wie der
internet explorer google wikipedia
facebook und natürlich auch youtube
grundlegend geprägt doch wie wird sich
das internet weiter entwickeln inwieweit
übernimmt künstliche intelligenz die
kontrolle hier die vier spannendsten
visionen über das internet der zukunft
herzlich willkommen bei klicks um
science-fiction
[Musik]
nächste woche bin ich am cern dort wo
sich der large hadron collider der
größte teilchenbeschleuniger der welt
befindet und das world wide web wurde
dort von tim berners-lee erfunden der
erste webserver stand dort auch in form
eines next cubes es war ein rechner den
damals steve jobs in seiner firma next
entwickelt hatte heute läuft eine
weiterentwicklung des betriebssystems
dieses rechners auf den modernen macs
aber das ist eine andere geschichte
kommen wir also zu den top 4
zukunftsvisionen für das internet es
gibt nämlich mehrere perspektiven wohin
die reise geht erste vision künstliche
intelligenz kontrolliert das internet
die vierte industrielle revolution im
internet experten und expertinnen sind
sich einig dass das netz schon bald
arbeiten automatisiert die bislang nur
menschen ausführen konnten und zwar
durch verschiedene anwendungen mit
künstlicher intelligenz und maschinellem
lernen ganz fabriken können gesteuert
werden die entwicklung von software
geschieht automatisch und auch eine
medizinische diagnose könnte demnächst
direkt im netz stattfinden denn das ist
auch klar die ki die künstliche
intelligenz im netz kann sehr viel
schneller riesige datenbanken
durchsuchen und abgleichen sowie muster
erkennen als wir menschen bleiben wir
mal im medizinischen bereich denn tech
firmen wie microsoft facebook amazon
apple und google sind fest davon
überzeugt das verständnis von
krankheiten sei letztlich ein daten
problem das gelöst werden muss die
instrumente künstliche intelligenz und
die analyse und auswertung riesiger
datenmengen innerhalb kürzester zeit
dazu ein konkretes beispiel aus der
praxis bei amazon geht es hauptsächlich
um virtuelle arztbesuche und darum wie
sich riesige datenmengen im
medizinischen bereich in einer cloud
speichern lassen oder das microsoft
projekt hannover computer sollen sich
zunächst einmal das komplette
medizinische wissen aneignen
heißt also studien lesen und verstehen
millionen von artikeln sind verfügbar
und täglich kommen neue erkenntnisse
hinzu schier unmöglich für uns menschen
kein großes problem dagegen für
maschinen statt einen wirkstoff nach dem
anderen zu testen könnte intelligente
software auf grundlage der genomischen
daten der patienten die literatur nach
der perfekt
medikamentenkombination durchsuchen auf
einen schlag können so tausende von
kombinationen analysiert werden und dem
ärzte-team vorgeschlagen werden durch
die zusammenarbeit mit dem menschen
könnten die maschinen dann sogar immer
weiter dazulernen und ihre intelligenz
ausbauen und das ist nicht das einzige
projekt das hoffnung macht ein bm hat
eine ki entwickelt die die dna
sequenzierung eines gehirntumors
schneller und zuverlässiger analysiert
hat als das gesamte team der
menschlichen experten und expertinnen in
israel arbeitet ein forschungsteam an
einem virtuellen gesundheits assistenten
der die patienten und patientinnen im
chat berät die maschine hat zugriff auf
eine riesige datenbank und allen
aufnahme protokollen bei wunsch zudem
auf die persönlichen daten der patienten
und patientinnen zweite visionen super
schneller und zuverlässiger
internetzugang auf der gesamten erde
richtig gutes und schnelles netz haben
wir hier in selbst in deutschland nur in
bestimmten regionen und großstädten in
ländlichen gebieten der wüste
abgelegenen inseln oder gar dem
dschungel sieht das ganz anders aus das
will ihnen mast mit seinem
raumfahrtunternehmen spacex ändern und
im laufe der nächsten jahre
kommunikationssatelliten in den
niedrigen orbit schicken die die ganze
welt umspannen so sollen alle an
schnellen zugang zum internet kommen
dieses ziel haben und hatten auch andere
doch der plan von mas übertrifft alle
anderen projekte sowohl in seiner
angepeilten zuverlässigkeit
verfügbarkeit und dimensionen bis 2025
soll das ganze netz aufgebaut sein
dessen konzept dann später so auch für
den mars übernommen werden soll auch das
unternehmen bleibt hat ähnliche pläne
und will ein netz aus knapp 900
satelliten aufbauen vielleicht gibt es
in zukunft aber auch vermehrt autonome
netze also wlan verbindungen die
zwischen einzelnen smartphones gebildet
werden beispielsweise wo du nach dem
schweren erdbeben in haiti ein messenger
entwickelt der nachrichten über ein peer
to peer netz weiterleitet denn ja über
weite strecken viel dort das gewöhnliche
internets aus dieses konzept nutzt die
möglichkeit moderne telefone gänzlich
autonome mesch
netze zu bilden das heißt also selbst
wenn das internet komplett ausfällt
können handys tablets und computer dann
ein eigenes autonomes unabhängiges netz
aufbauen dritte vision menschliche
gehirne werden mit dem internet
verbunden
wir haben darüber hier bei pixum science
fiction berichtet erst vor kurzem ist es
am forschungsteam tatsächlich gelungen
zum ersten mal das menschliche gehirn
mit dem internet zu verbinden und in
zukunft sollen dann auch daten wirklich
auf unser gehirn übertragbar sein das
experiment aus washington hat deutlich
gemacht dass die kommunikation zwischen
zwei menschen die hirnströme über das
internet austauschen schon jetzt
funktioniert und auch viele unternehmen
haben genau diese vision beispielsweise
der unternehmer allen masc mit seiner
firma neuling ja da mal wieder hätte das
gedacht in seinen vorstellungen können
wir in einigen jahrzehnten elektronische
geräte direkt mit unserem gehirn
verbinden und zwar mit hilfe
implantierter chips im hirn die bits und
bytes in gedanken über setzen können und
umgekehrt auch facebook hat ähnliche
pläne
menschen sollen demnächst direkt aus dem
gehirn heraus worte im computer
schreiben lassen
100 worte pro minute das ist das ziel
das forschungsteam von facebook seien
nun dabei sehr empfindliche sensoren zu
entwickeln die die aktivität im gehirn
sehr genau verfolgen können
so wäre es dann auch nicht mehr
notwendig die einzelnen buchstaben im
kopf zu bilden was zudem dazu führen
könnte dass wir bald auch andere
sprachen sprechen könnten und zwar ohne
sie vorher zu lernen
der gedanke an einen behälter in der
hand aus dem an flüssigkeit trinken kann
könnte dann direkt mit dem
entsprechenden fremdwort für tasse auf
japanisch oder englisch umgesetzt werden
falls dies alles funktioniert würde es
die welt wie wir sie kennen komplett
umkrempeln anstatt eine e mail zu tippen
würde es ausreichend einfach kurz an den
gewünschten inhalt zu denken der
computer verwandelt unsere gedanken dann
in den entsprechenden text um zudem
hätten wir zugriff auf die gedanken und
erfahrungen anderer menschen so könnten
wir also problemlos die erfahrung von
anderen erleben zb die eines promis oder
eines soldaten auch wenn wir bestimmte
fachwissen haben wollen müssen wir nur
an diesen wunschdenken und könnten schon
den gedanken entsprechender experten und
expertinnen herunterladen vierte
visionen super sicheres internet durch
quanten vielleicht hat das ja
mitbekommen
ich war letztens an der uni in wien zum
einen habe ich selbst dort einen vortrag
gehalten
zum anderen aber auch professor philip
walther einen der experten für
quantenkryptographie weltweit kennen
gelernt die forschung ist an der
universität wien schon extrem weit seit
mitte letzten jahres den sind die
hoffnungen groß in sachen quanten netz
den chinesischen satelliten mikio sehen
viele als den vorboten einer neuen ära
wenn er überträgt quanten verschränkte
infrarot photonen daten statt
radiowellen und das absolut abhörsicher
im fachmagazin nature vermeldete ein
forschungsteam aus china dann das
unfassbare nicos war tatsächlich in der
lage den wichtigsten schritt zu
absolvieren
die sogenannte quantenkryptographie
konkret heißt das dass der quanten code
über eine distanz von rund 2500
kilometer zwischen peking und wien
ausgetauscht werden konnte und das auch
noch bis zu 100 trillionen mal
effizienter als ein glasfaser
das ist wirklich ein absoluter
meilenstein werden tatsächlich
lichtteilchen übertragen nur wenn das
einzelne teilchen ankommt funktioniert
das system nebel oder wolken können das
komplett verhindern in einigen wenigen
jahrzehnten könnte auf dieser basis ein
quanten satellitennetz entstehen das
absolute abhörsichere kommunikation
weltweit ermöglicht denn nur die quanten
schüssel müssen über die satelliten
übertragen werden die verschlüsselte
kommunikation funktioniert dann ganz
normal über das internet denn das ganze
läuft so falls der übertragende
schlüssel abgefangen wird geht die
verschränkung der photonen kaputt und
das merken sowohl sender als auch
empfänger der schlüssel kann nicht
verwendet werden experten und
expertinnen sind sie schon heute einig
dass es schwierig sein wird die
herrschaft im netz zu behalten nicht nur
das militär sondern auch geheimdienste
oder kriminelle können die
sicherheitslücken im internet nutzen um
vorteile für sich herauszuholen geld
oder macht die quanten
fotografie wäre ein wichtiger schritt zu
einem sicheren netz ja wenn ihr keine
videos zur entwicklung des internets und
zu allen anderen themen verpassen wollt
dann endet mich bei whatsapp dann um
geht ihr die kaputte abo box hier auf
youtube und verpasst kein video
denn über whatsapp erfahrt ihr von mir
noch vor allen anderen vom neuesten
video täglich und garantiert einfach
hier draufklicken und am besten auch
meinen schwesterkanal klicks um social
and media abonnieren da gibt es das
neueste aus der social media welt dafür
hier klicken aber nicht ganz wichtig die
genau die glocke vergessen und hier geht
es weiter mit dafür auch draufklicken
online überholt fernsehen bis dann
bleibt dran